la pregunta está en Boca de todos desde
principios de enero y finalmente tiene
respuesta según Fuentes oficiales y el
famoso diario alemán permitirá que
países como Polonia entreguen sus
leopard a Ucrania una información que
parece confirmada por la vicepresidenta
del bundestag el parlamento Alemán los
leopards se han liberado Ojalá ahora
puedan ayudar rápidamente a Ucrania en
su lucha contra el ataque Ruso y por la
libertad de Ucrania y Europa el kremlin
aseguró el martes que estas entregas de
tanques alemanes no juraban nada bueno
es un plan destinado al fracaso muchos
especialistas son conscientes de lo
absurdo que es el envío de tanques
pesados está sobreestimado sin embargo
la mala premonición Sería para el
ejército ruso porque son increíblemente
eficaces y significaría una prueba del
compromiso de sus aliados con Ucrania
una información procedente de Berlín que
probablemente genere preocupación en
Moscú el gobierno alemán había advertido
que sólo aceptaría el envío de tanques a
ucra y Estados Unidos también enviaba
sus tanques abrams según los medios de
comunicación estadounidenses de
confirmarse esta decisión alemana podría
ir acompañada de un anuncio de
Washington algo que sería un golpe
especialmente duro para los rusos y
daría un poco de aire a los ucranianos
en medio de